Scot you're viewed Dead Rising 4 so tell
me overall what are your thoughts like
before we dive into nitty-gritty yeah I
mean I think your your summary was fair
it's it is a fun game I really enjoyed
it but it's also kind of retreading well
ground it's doing a lot of the same
stuff the series is always done I don't
know that it necessarily does much of it
better I mean it sort of depends on the
aspect of the game you're talking about
but yeah I mean it is more Dead Rising
do you like hitting zombies with wacky
objects do you like kind of dark humor
and open-world settings and like this is
the game for you yeah I played it a few
preview events and again like you said
it did feel very much like Dead Rising 3
to me kind of like they were just
embracing the chaos of things they're
embracing the creativity of the kills
not that I wanted to didn't have that
but I feel like three really lean olena
that crafting for kind of expounded upon
that with the like mods up to your
actual like body the exosuit right how
much did that because that was what I
was looking for not much actually like
so that you can sort of find them around
the world and certain campaign missions
kind of force you into one but
unfortunately you can't just like it's
not like something you can unlock and
have with you at all times it's just
something that's like occasionally as
this like brief moment you get to mess
around in an exosuit I mean it's
actually just a really really minor part
of the experience and it's fun when it
comes up like it's super super powerful
so you are essentially invincible for
the duration it's like getting a star in
Mario right you guys like completely run
through and destroy everything in front
of you for like 30 to 40 seconds and
that's pretty cool but you know the fun
kind of wears off after a little while
so lay out the structure for me I'm
seeing like these almost like graphic
novel ass cutscenes but I'm also seeing
you know like just this massive open
world where as you know the first two
games were kind of on this timer
I believe the countdown timer has not
returned since reverie ditched it yeah
what do you think of the overall
structure Dead Rising 4 in its
open-world and whatnot yes so there's
actually one like little bit of the
motion graphic comic thing right at the
very beginning for the most part it's
actually told through fully realized
cutscenes which is nice I feel like more
and more games are kind of shoving their
storytelling into like weird exposition
dumps over like semi static images so I
appreciate the Dead Rising 4 actually
gives you full cutscenes with the
characters interacting and you actually
see the story happening in
real-time as opposed to having someone
tell you about what's going on later on
so that's actually really nice I was
surprised the story was really good so
for the most part it is a linear story
told within an open world so if you
choose to follow the campaign you are
following like you can't choose what
mission you're doing you just move on to
the next thing but at anytime you can
kind of just run around this giant world
and it is I think the biggest world in a
Dead Rising game so I mean yeah it's a
very traditional structure but a very
strong story for the series the writing
was better I would say than it has been
in previous games there like sudden
moments of seriousness that are kind of
almost jarring in a good way
relative to the silliness of the action
like every now and then the game takes
itself just seriously enough that it
hits you with this like impactful
emotional moment and it kind of keeps
you invested in what's happening yeah I
mean even from the preview events I
played in thinking back to three Cantley
some be just fun and crafting new
weapons crafting the vehicles now
crafting yourself as they were saying it
seems like it would get monotonous after
a while did it do enough to shake it up
after a while I mean you can craft new
weapons but you're still just plowing
through these so yeah you hit on like
the biggest thing I didn't really like
about the game which is that yeah the
combat is it's very repetitive and
unchanged from previous games and it's
very superficial you will spend most of
the game just mashing the light-attack
button as you like mow down the zombies
directly in front of you with whatever
you happen to have handy which yes it's
totally like fun in a superficial kind
of way for a while but it does wear a
little thin and again the story is
actually pretty strong so it'll keep you
interested through the end and the combo
weapons are genuinely funny and it's fun
to kind of seek out new blueprints and
see what the world has to offer because
there are all kinds of surprises the
world is actually very deep tons of
stuff laying around tons a little secret
should uncover and part of that is the
combo weapons so there's enough to keep
you interested but yeah the core combat
like the main portion of the gameplay is
a little boring and repetitive and
actually the circle back to something
you mentioned that I totally glazed over
and didn't mean to the timer so the
timer used to kind of keep that
interesting like yeah the combat wasn't
super exciting but you were under the
gun like you had a timer ticking down so
it felt really tense you almost didn't
care that the actual combat was like
mechanically kind of routine right
because you were so focused on
oh I gotta get here and get rescue this
person to do this thing so when you
remove the timer it does allow the open
world to breathe you can actually go
explore and enjoy everything that's out
there and again there is a lot but it
does remove some of that tension that
really drove the earliest games like the
very first game in my mind was memorable
because of that structure because it had
the timer so it loses some of its
identity without that timer but a lot of
people also hated it they that
restriction so you know it's a trade-off
I love the timer - like you said it kind
of alleviated some of the monotony of
just killing these zombies and like you
know planning out what you're gonna do
with the time you have I'm gonna go
rescue the survivor or like fight this
mini boss or yeah like whatever but it
sounds like even outs like when ditching
the timer in Dead Rising 4 it sounds
like you said it was pretty easy in
general outside of that like it whether
it's zombies or human enemies that
you're forget it's oh it's super easy
like and there's no difficulty setting
to be clear it's not like I play it
uneasy nope there's one setting that's
it and yeah I mean I don't think I ever
well I never died I definitely I never
died once in the entire game I committed
suicide one so I could respawn somewhere
else because I was kind of trapped in an
area that was it was the only time so
including boss battles including fights
with the like super agile new zombies
that are introduced to this game never
once even really came close to dying
which he has a pretty sharp contrast to
the very first game in this series where
you could very easily fail you could run
out of time people would dive you didn't
get to them quickly enough like all
kinds of things could go wrong in this
game it really is more just about the
fun of smashing things up and
slaughtering zombies and you know making
your way through the story which is fine
I mean it is fun in like kind of a
popcorn entertainment kind of way like I
said in the review so it's it's it's
good 7 is a good score right but it's
not it's not great yeah but it's it's
good but were there any like really
standout moments that like you're gonna
like really remember about your
experience with the game or is it all
just so chaotic and silly that none of
it really stands out I mean yeah on the
spot there's nothing that comes to mind
it's like oh my god you have to play it
to see this mo Mac yeah right but there
is like just overall I really liked the
tone of the game I thought the humor was
actually pretty well executed is this
nice mix of
Chiqui smart satirical humor and stuff
that's just totally goofy and silly I
really like Frank his portrayal in this
game he's the returning protagonist was
very first game he can be a little
grating at times Bizzy is like kind of a
frustrating [ __ ] it's at moments and
he's kind of arrogant but that can be
really funny like he makes all kinds of
commentary throughout the campaign
there's all of his little quips and
asides or pretty entertaining and and
ultimately endearing so I mean there's
broad things I like about the game that
made me want to keep playing and it made
me enjoy my time overall
but yeah nothing that's like you know
it's gonna stick with me through you
know next year or the year after or I'm
just thinking back on something about it
yeah yeah reminder like Dead Rising 3
was one of my early Xbox one games and I
remember I was kind of that was one of
the ones that return to it was almost
cathartic despite the fact that it's
it's supposed to be based around that
you know like it's not a really a
survival game it is about an undead
apocalypse and everything I found a kind
of ironic that I would go to that game
when I wanted to relax and just like
plow through zombies and everything do
you have any like I don't know do you
have any standout weapons you crafted or
vehicles that you can not to put you on
the spot I'm sure I'm seeing like the
gameplay were looking at now shows a few
there's like a forklift that he did
something with this is kind of an
interesting thing I thought about
talking about this more in the review
but it was a little too like into the
weeds and I just ultimately decided to
cut it but here's the thing that's
interesting to me about the combo
weapons when it was a survival game
finding certain elements in creating
combo weapons felt super special it was
like oh my god I have this thing that's
gonna keep me alive like I'm so excited
like alright yeah in the first game like
hunting down a mini chainsaw which is
like the best weapon in the game felt so
meaningful you were so excited to have
it while it lasted because every every
weapon was and remains disposable they
all break but it used to be so crucial
to your survival that it was super
exciting to get something good in Dead
Rising 4 everything's kind of disposable
cuz there you're always gonna find
something cool right around the next
corner guaranteed like no matter where
you are in the game you're gonna find
something and make something weird yeah
you're in a suit of armor just mowing
that guy's down with an axe if you're
not getting attached to that what are
you gonna get attached to or everything
it's funny it's funny and it's fun and
it's silly and that's kind of great in
its own right but yeah it kind of stops
being rewarding so to answer your
question my favorite weapon my go-to
weapon was the ice
sword one because it froze on beach was
mechanically was very useful because
they tended to mob you because they're
zombies but also because it was just
such an easy weapon to craft i mean you
need like a can of nitros or a can of um
liquid nitrogen which for whatever
reason is in every single place that
serves food is like any any restaurant
anything like that you're guaranteed to
find at least a couple of those there's
all throughout the game doing wizards
yes yes exactly that like I could always
like rely on finding a new ice sword so
that was my go-to weapon for the entire
game just saying it was powerful and
super easy to crack yeah
yeah I mean like I said this seems like
a game I'm gonna return to once I finish
all the other like I don't know the Last
Guardian Final Fantasy and what and
whatnot you know and not to detract from
Dead Rising 4 it seems like a game
that's you know seems timeless I can go
back to it whenever else they'll have
the same fun I would have fun you know
when it released today
it's a palate cleanser right it's not
like the it sticks with you and changes
your perception of games you have to
tell everyone you know about it but it's
like the man like I really want to kill
some time I really want to relax or just
do something fun and mindless and you
know maybe even get some cool story
along the way like this is that game and
it's it's great for that purpose yeah
awesome yeah I'm looking forward to
playing more of that that is dead rising
force that is out today December 6 for
Xbox one and Microsoft Windows Scott
gave it a 7 out of 10 you can go read
his more in-depth review on GameSpot
calm
[Music]